Lockheed Martin's f-35 check is the most  expensive plane in military history and  it's had a bumpy ride experiencing  everything from engine fires to budget  issues  now it's adding one more problem to the  list doesn't like the heat specifically  its fuels Heat the f-35 is designed to  use its fuel as a cooling agent if that  fuel gets too warm it can cause the  whole jet to shut down since fuel  tankers spend long hours in direct  sunlight they often cook their cargo to  an unusable temperature for the stealth  fighter Air Force bases in Arizona in  California are repainting their fuel  trucks from green to white to reflect  the sun's rays the problem is white  makes them easier targets and combat  zones the next step is to test a colored  paint that won't conduct as much heat  long-term the Air Force's answer to the  problem you're building parking shades